with reaction fox news contributor joe
concha former trump
senior adviser stephen miller thank you
both for being with us stephen i'll
start with you
okay i watched what happened today
been watching what happened all week
i've been watching what happened last
week i've been watching what happened
the week before
this is now to me it is of
an acute serious significant situation
unfolding your thoughts
as you mentioned sean it's a national
security crisis
because our adversaries around the world
iran
russia venezuela china they're watching
this they're looking at this they're
looking at the united states
it's chief representative the president
of our country
who's unable to get through even a
softball interview without a cheat sheet
who falls down not once not twice but
three times going up a flight of stairs
and it's sad to watch i take
no pleasure in it just like you said
this isn't to be
funny this is extremely serious by the
way i'll note
i've walked up and down those stairs
many times many times they're not
slippery sean
the air force goes to great lengths to
make sure those tears are not slippery
there's a very carefully placed carpet
that's a non-slip surface
and so to slip three times going up this
flight of stairs
that's a pretty serious problem just
from a pure health standpoint
you know i'm looking at this and i think
it is sad and
you know i'm torn here i feel bad for
him joe
it's it's embarrassing for the country
and then
steven's right because now we've got
look at what i i felt putin was pretty
much mocking him
this week that's how i interpreted it
and then we're getting lectured by the
the chinese on human rights and
the answer is well at least we apologize
for our mistakes
and that was the answer instead of going
back at them
excuse me we're not going to get lecture
for you from you on human rights
and by the way look what you did to the
world with the virus and you hid it from
the world
yeah when they see a president sean that
hasn't given a press conference and
won't
a solo one anyway for nine weeks into
his presidency that's longer than
any of his predecessors going back a
hundred years when they see that he
isn't going to even address
the joint session of congress that's
basically the state of the union every
president in the modern era has done
that
in february we may not hear this until
may
the answer the question is why but when
you play those clips in aggregate
the way the way that was just set up and
i hadn't really seen it laid out that
way
before it is unsettling to watch because
to steven's point
this isn't a 78 year old who's working
too long at the food king and maybe you
should retire
this is the leader of the free world and
now the media this is a nice big test
for them
because in june of 2020 to your point
earlier when president trump
simply walked down a wet ramp in dress
shoes
no railings wasn't wearing air jordans
or anything like that he didn't
fall at all he didn't fall not once but
twice but thrice as you're seeing with
mr biden here
and yet the cnn headline quote why the
donald trump west point ramp story
actually matters that's what they said
in june of 2020.
tonight on cnn's website white house
says biden is 100
fine after he tripped boarding air force
one tripped as if that's only singular
and then also washington post june of
2020 headline
trump mocked by late night hosts for
slow walk down
west point ramp how much you want to bet
colbert
and kimmel and seth meyers don't even
touch this with a 30-foot pole because
obviously you can't offend anybody in
these situations by doing comedy it's
going to make anybody uncomfortable
so look it's very fair to ask when the
president forgets his defense secretary
name
in lloyd austin or the building that he
works in the pentagon or he calls the
vice president
again president harris or again the fact
that he is
not even addressed a joint session of
congress you have to wonder or visit the
border for that matter where there's a
crisis in fact
fema is down there so that makes it a
disaster he won't even visit it
what is wrong with president biden and
it's not an attack to ask that question
it is a fair question that half of
americans are asking tonight sean
how do you interpret what putin and and
china are now
pretty much saying i interpreted putin
basically taking a shot at joe biden and
the country
and basically saying really you want to
debate
like mockingly steve miller
they're openly they're openly mocking us
they're openly mocking
president biden it's humiliating and
that humiliation is compounded by the
fact
that when you have a commander-in-chief
who's not home
who's not present who's not there then
you have embarrassing episodes like what
happened in alaska
where china dares to lecture us on human
rights
and blinking and sullivan just sit there
and take it
they apologize it can happen it's
because
and they apologize for america how does
that happen sean
it happens when you have no leadership
at the top
when the president isn't home and other
countries
see that weakness and they are pouncing
and we're
all less safe as a result all right
thank you both
joe concha steve miller